la mairie se prépare son carnaval de
printemps pour faire vibrer les rues de
trappes aux rythmes afro antillais la
compagnie difé kako propose des ateliers
de danse pour petits et grands
ces ateliers sont ouverts à tous
danseurs initiés ou non c'est vraiment
avec la régularité que les gens viennent
et apprécient ce qu'ils font et ça
marche et puis de toute façon c'est une
ambiance de groupe partir du moment le
groupe était ensemble et qu'on s'amuse
ensemble c'est l'énergie du groupe qui
compte
cet événement festif savant mélange de
musique et de chorégraphie favorise
ainsi la rencontre entre toutes les
générations
déjà j'aime la danse puis je voulais
voir comment c'était la danse africaine
et puis c'est vraiment super bien bas
ont fait des gestes qu'on fait pas d'un
dedans c'est vraiment une mention
spéciale il sait très bien c'est dans
une ambiance conviviale que se déroule
pour la première fois la merise les
préparatifs pour un défilé carnavalesque
il est encore possible de s'inscrire aux
ateliers avant la grande parade du 23
mars